[Musique]
j'ai tenté ma chance à tête marque parc
d'attraction avec debbie vraiment
compter
bromont gars on était adepte par ce week
end c'était dingue mais c'est pas comme
les parcs d'attraction à la con où tu as
les zombies qui sont foutus derrière des
grillages vie pour rien non j'en étais
avec eux tu les vois les gens ils
peuvent
t'choupi pasta grippé quoi mais ça va tu
es sûr ouais ouais ouais ça m'aurait de
la dragonne tenteront de venir au monde
et jeté dans un couloir comme ça s'est
fait courser par des zombies
il me poursuivre poursuit il saute
dessus pour bouffer et c'est pas cher
aura eu mon pote
non les mecs vous êtes fait mordre la
foire fait quoi hélas non cadrée et où
il ya des vigiles enfin voila c'est un
parc dont anecdote je me retrouve à un
moment face à de zombies ils verront dit
vas-y toi tu fais tu fais moi et nous on
fait les ongles au début j'avais avec
les deux biches puisqu'au débute demain
pied de biche genre c'est la démerde
quand tu vois je reporte un pied de nez
à ses invités un casque et là je me
retrouve face à eux je me planque
derrière un petit muret je sors plus
festive que tu sors de deux derrière la
palissade tu fais moi est une guerrière
du sort résiste
rien
[Musique]
mais non ça n'a pas du tout la ici
savoir on sait les hobbies quoi joue un
peu le truc mon bref ils m'attaquent
là je perds mon pied de biche et là je
me retrouve avec leur petite gueule au
sein de la mienne s'imagine pas la fille
je peux pas vous êtes des pétards tombé
au tapis toi non lâche ce chapeau moche
ça 2 0l ouais t'es malade ou quoi que tu
poses de bras ça attention avec ce fait
attention je vous des coupes des coupes
les genoux arrête tes clairement sous
pression tu as vraiment besoin de calme
ça va très bien ça va mieux que toi tu
poses ce bras tu poses le plumeau le
bras d'abord pose mon bras en même temps
en même temps le jeu décalé ont décalé
légèrement déclic
ça va aller au quai vallet
[Musique]
je comprends pas
en seine et marne un jeune homme pris de
démence soudaine a menacé ses deux
collègues à l'aide d'engins tout de
suite la météo
[Applaudissements]
vraiment à ce moment là je prends les
ciseaux et je vais me navre mais bon là
maintenant ça fait un an et ça va
beaucoup mieux merci les gars c'est pas
souvent qu'on est ensemble on prend une
photo
ah oui oui attention
[Musique]
on va passer à l'étape des lentilles de
contact donc sa première fois de ma vie
que ça devrait bien se passer
non c'est faux pas
vous êtes sûr j'aurai le visage de
bradley cooper après